wir vereinbarten ein treffen in zheshov äh
joshua ist die stadt
nahe der polnisch-ukrainischen grenze und
wir trafen uns dort zusammen mit dem
premierminister der tschechischen republik, dem
slowenischen
premierminister und präsident kaczynski und wir gingen zusammen
in die apotheke, weil wir in shemesh waren
Wir hatten einen vorab vereinbarten Zug,
wir starteten früh am Morgen, wir
kamen
gegen 19.00
Uhr an,
ähm, Kiewer Zeit, vielleicht etwas später
als
19.00 Uhr, ähm, ukrainischer Zeit, nicht während
der Reise, wo wir tatsächlich
durch die Städte fuhren, die waren
Uns vorgeschlagen und von unseren
ukrainischen Partnern ausgewählt. Ich
möchte mich auch bei Premierminister Mihawk bedanken,
der uns bei der Organisation all dessen geholfen hat, damit
die Reise
so sicher war, wie sie während
der Kriegszeiten die
ganze
Zeit nicht war  das wichtigste
für mich, als ich
an diese frauen und kinder dachte
, die jeden tag bombardiert werden,
sagte ich mir,
europa muss dieses äh
massive äh verbrechen stoppen, das äh
das von t begangen wird  er von den russen und
von putin, also war das für mich das
wichtigste und und die risiken, die die
leute
in der ukraine auf sich nehmen, diese ukrainischen soldaten, die
für
ihre und unsere freiheit kämpfen,
ähm, ist viel so viel größer als ii
nicht  so viel Konzentration auf die
Risiken unseres Premierministers und Präsidenten unserer Fraktion,
wo,
wenn ich das sagen darf, während der Kriegszeit
das Wort glücklich nicht angebracht ist, aber
sie waren sehr, sehr
zufrieden mit unserer Anwesenheit dort, weil
dies sichtbar war
zeichen unserer einigkeit und
wir sichtbares zeichen dafür, dass europa
die
ukraine nicht isoliert verlässt ukraine kann
heutzutage nicht isoliert werden sie
kämpft wirklich mit löwenherzen
für unsere sicherheit auch präsident
zowenski ist ein
wahrer führer
oberbefehlshaber
und staatsmann und und prime  minister
mihal ist auch ein sehr starker führer in
diesen schwierigen schrecklichen zeiten und
sie suchen überall nach unterstützung
, aber gleichzeitig geben
sie nicht auf  d Sie werden sich nicht
ergeben, sie werden kämpfen, bis die
allerletzte Straße
verteidigt ist, das allerletzte
Wohnhaus, das jetzt
von den
Russen angefahren wird
der europäische rat
und ich nahm auch ein vorab arrangiertes paket
zusätzlicher unterstützung.
es gibt diese riesige unterstützung, ähm, wenn sie
durch die polnische grenze in die ukraine geht, ist
es hauptsächlich eine humanitäre hilfe,
aber auch eine defensive waffe,
und das ist übrigens das, was
sie brauchen, fragen sie uns  hauptsächlich,
um ihnen zu helfen, ihre grenzen zu verteidigen,
um ihre häuser zu verteidigen, rufe ich um
kanzler schultz, äh, premierminister, boris johnson,
äh, natürlich, präsident joe biden,
präsident emmanuel macron auf, dorthin zu gehen
, um äh in die augen von frauen
und kindern
der ukraine zu schauen  und um ihnen zu helfen,
ihr Leben zu retten, hoffe ich,
dass die jüngste Änderung der Kehrtwende, wie Sie
sagten, ähm,
nicht nur sinnvoll ist, sondern von Dauer sein
wird  es wird länger
dauern, weil es so wichtig ist und deutschland, dass
deutschland ihre
wahren
ziele der kremlpolitik versteht, wir müssen
sagen
, die kriegsmaschinerie des setzens zu stoppen ist
gleich stoppen,
äh, gas und öl von putin zu kaufen, wie man
frieden erzwingt
zum Frieden zurückzukehren,
ist durch sehr harte Wirtschaftssanktionen
, die Wirtschaftssanktionen zerschlagen, und das ohne
Ausnahmen